you are watching ColdFusion TV the
silent battle has been going on for
eight long years two different
underlying philosophies two different
types of users almost two different
worlds one side value stability
ease-of-use and simplicity this is
Apple's iOS the other side values
openness choice and customization this
is Google's Android the rivalry between
these OSS is also personal to a large
percentage of the population who own a
smartphone the most personal device of
all this is part one of a two-part
series on Android versus iOS in these
videos we'll take an interesting look at
the brief history of both Android and
iOS weigh out the pros and cons of each
and then we'll take a look at what
conclusions we can draw these one better
than the other or is that even the right
question to be asking there's a lot to
this story but to really understand it
we have to go to the beginning by
looking at the history of each operating
system in context we can understand
their philosophies completely let's
begin
in 2005 when Steve Jobs was first
envisioning the iPhone either he could
make a miniature version of the Mac or
enlarge the iPod which was Apple's main
portable products at the time into a
fine
Steve assigned to different teams within
Apple to perceive both options the team
in charge of scaling down the Mac
created the iPhone OS now known as iOS
now software on mobile phones is like
it's like baby software it's not so
powerful and today we're going to show
you a software or breakthrough software
that's at least five years ahead of
what's on any other phone now how do we
do this well we start with a strong
foundation iPhone runs OS 10 so why did
Steve ultimately choose to scale down
the Mac well there's two main reasons
the first one Mac OS was already
complete it had animations sound power
management and many other things built
in why would you want to reinvent the
wheel when you could just optimize the
software and get it to fit in a smaller
package the second reason is that Steve
neither software inside and out this
knowledge helped him no to optimizing
software to shrink the Mac's down into a
phone was indeed possible such deep
involvement is often rare for a modern
CEO so we have to ask how exactly did
Steve know the software so well as it
turns out Mac OS was actually made from
the remnants of a software called next
step next step was developed by Steve
Jobs when he was fired from Apple in
1985 as a frontside point the world wide
web was actually built on a next step
system in 1989 by Tim berners-lee if you
want to know more you can check out a
video that I did on the history of the
internet in the description below
in 1997 Apple bought next step which
brought Steve Jobs back as the CEO over
the years next step was developed
further to finally become Mac OS which
as we know finally became iOS so in
actuality iowa's didn't just fall from
the sky it had a rich history all the
way back from early 1986
this is one of the major reasons why iOS
was so polished from the get-go Android
on the other hand was a bit of an
experiment upon release founded in
October 2003 by Andy Rubin rich Mena
Nick Sears and Chris way Android was
initially supposed to be digital camera
software of course early on it was clear
that this market was way too small so
the company concentrated on producing a
smartphone OS that could take on Nokia
Symbian and Microsoft's Windows Mobile
it all started when I first met Andy who
was CEO of danger and I was working at
t-mobile we also had another friend in
common and the three of us all believed
that it was too difficult to get new
products out to consumers in a timely
fashion and we thought the missing link
was not having an open platform and
that's how Android got started in July
2005 Google acquired Android
incorporated for over 50 million dollars
with this capital Android began
developing prototype phones early
Android prototypes were more like
blackberries that is they had no
touchscreen and a physical QWERTY
keyboard later prototypes were later
re-engineered to support a touchscreen
to compete with other announced devices
such as the 2006 LG Prada and of course
the iPhone in 2007 on November 5th 2007
an industry watershed moment occurred
the Open Handset Alliance was unveiled
the Alliance was an effort to develop
open standards for mobile devices
it included HTC Sony Samsung Sprint
t-mobile and chip manufacturers such as
Qualcomm Google knew they couldn't do it
alone the first commercially available
smart phone running Android was the HTC
dream in late 2008 although it was
rather jangly and didn't seem to fit
together very well
heavy Gmail integration widgets and
useful pulldown settings menu along with
almost limitless customization set
Android apart the lag enos of the HTC
dream and other early Android devices
when compared to the iPhone
results in the negative perception in
the minds of the average uninformed
consumer it did also do some brand
damage to the operating system early on
since then however Android phones have
changed greatly over time over the years
Android became more refined less buggy
and overall more polished okay so that's
all well and good but some of you might
want some practical quantifiable proof
of this how has Android performance in
comparison to the iPhone changed over
time well in early 2014 the touch
response time for a high-end Android
phone was around 114 milliseconds at
best in comparison to this the iPhone 5
and 5s came in at a blistering 75
milliseconds but by the end of 2014 new
Android phones had come to the market
and things had changed in that short
amount of time as shown by the data here
the top smartphones were actually more
responsive than the current iPhone at
the time all right so I've been talking
a lot about how Android has changed over
time but what about Apple well as you
would have guessed these changes weren't
only limited to Android iOS has also
changed a great deal over time a lot of
the early limitations pertaining to
options and features have been lifted
iPhones are now a far cry away from
having no video camera or copy and paste
now there's a choice of two phone sizes
a notification center low-power mode and
limited multitasking Android viewers may
note that a lot of these things have
arguably been borrowed from Android okay
so with all that history out of the way
and all that said that brings us to the
present day which OS is better today
looking objectively today stock iPhones
still lag behind Android in terms of
functionality but is this necessarily a
bad thing to the benefits of iOS
outweigh the cons or is it flip to the
other side does Android hold the key to
success in a spoken this and choice in
the next episode we'll take a look at
the app environment user base pros and
cons issues and features of both Android
and iOS
after this we'll finish off with what's
in store for the future
where are Android and iOS both going
it's going to be a great video so stay
tuned anyway this has been to go go
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up leave a comment and subscribe if
you're new and want to thank you for
watching and I'll see you again soon for
another video cheers guys have a good
one
cold fusion
it's rethinking